what you're about to watch is a special
private training session for people who
bought a copy of my book built to serve
enjoy
i'm feeling workshop mode today who's
got something that i can help with
tanya's got her hand up what do we got
tanya yes hello evan hello everyone so
good to see your faces every week i'm
having this you know um
kind of like starting exercises about
how to share
my story like storytelling because most
of my life i've been you know i love
stories but i've been the listener not
really the ones that shares
so i'm kind of like
learning how to do it and
um one thing that i find challenging is
because
when you share right and uh in and you
don't want to share specific parts of it
because any consideration personal
whatever consideration right
how do you feel like or how do you
manage that feeling of being less
authentic if you don't share them
you know
that those those parts that you don't
want to share and not because you don't
want to share them because of you
sometimes you do it because it's not
only your story
it belongs to someone else too and that
someone else deserves the right to tell
the story in their own terms and they
are not going to have that audience
and uh you don't wanna you know you
don't want to own
you don't wanna put that person on the
spot yeah if there was not you know
yeah yeah
well first let's let's acknowledge you
because you you're sharing your story
right here
yeah like you're doing it
and i remember when you first joined uh
this group
the first couple times you didn't say
anything
never raised your hand you know zayn
zen had to pick on you and say okay
tanya
you gotta share something
[Laughter]
and he pulled you in and then here
i said hey guys i'm let's just do a q a
you know and for anybody new here
welcome uh i'd like to have this group
for people who've you know got the book
and have it be resource and um you know
do some support in ongoing communities
so you're not alone on your journey and
as soon as i said hey you're going to do
q a tanya's hand is like the first one
up
right what a what a change over the past
i don't know the couple months it hasn't
been that long
um so
you're already doing it you're already
way ahead of what you were doing before
you're already sharing is and it's
awesome
um
now inside of any story that you're
sharing
some of the things i'll always do not
always but often do is change change the
gender change the relationship if it's
somebody else
um because usually that doesn't matter
so in i mean the book that i just wrote
if i'm saying somebody's name
that you're you know you're one of the
readers for the beta readers for the
group um
i cleared it with them so there's a
really personal story about nina in
there obviously cleared it with her
before posted it i wrote it and then
uh i let her read it afterwards and i
think i wrote even in the book i don't
know if this is even going to make it
into the book
and and then i asked her the next day
and she's like yeah i just included it's
like you know you might want to read it
first
and then she write it and she started
crying and she said no it's okay put put
it in
um i talk about mark and i talk about um
my agent steve in the book and i use
their names and i i
i wrote to them and asked them hey
here's what i wrote are you okay with it
being in the book and they both said yes
there's other people that i talk about
where
details minor details might change
gender might change a city therein might
change because that stuff doesn't really
matter
um
and then for other people that you just
might have to
not talk about it you know there's lots
that i don't share about my parents
because they're very private people
so you know a couple stories
um but most of the stuff with them i
don't share
and and i love my parents like they're
on my wall you know in front of me here
but because they're private and they
don't want you know content living on
the internet about them then i don't i
don't talk about it
it's just knowing that you have enough
other stories
you know there's enough other things
that are happening that don't involve
other people or you can share your
perspective that still provide
tremendous value to people
and and
even again back to what you just did
today
you raised your hand and what did you
share you shared that you are having
uh doubts or anxiety around
how do i share stories
yeah like you're doing it it's your
perspective without throwing somebody
else under the bus
i'm not in the throw people under the
bus
category um
some people might be it's like no like
that guy is a loser and i'm gonna let
the world know that he's a loser he's
like okay cool like if that's your style
go for it but um
there's a lot you can share without
having to tell somebody else's side and
and i hear you it's their story to share
um
there's so many other stories that you
could tell that still gives a lot of
value to people
does that make sense
uh yes like i need to yeah i was doing
this kind of like
self-exercise about okay why do i feel
so uncomfortable or how can i manage
this should i
you know let leave this uh storytelling
at the side at all maybe i'm you know
not
not that good at it i don't know many
thoughts and uh what i end up concluding
and you know what you are doing
makes sense because probably i need to
to to to choose why what i want to share
and
why like not need to share everything to
feel authentic
that's that's kind of like the thing
right if i don't share
some things would i feel less authentic
and uh well i need to find out what are
those things that
are
are good to share are fine to share they
may be difficult
but
at the same time won't affect anybody
else because that's the last thing that
i want to do right so it's kind of like
that exercise of going over and over and
see how can i share my story what do i
want to share and why why do i want to
share i just want to start talking about
something just because i want more
people to follow me
no i don't want that i have a purpose so
i just need to find
what i want to share why and
i guess that little by little i find out
how you know
doing these exercises and trying to get
better i'll find how to share in like a
more effective way
so yeah what you're saying yeah makes
sense yeah choose what you want to share
like yeah definitely
and that doesn't make me less authentic
right
yeah so like if you were going to share
a story of
of one of your students
that you helped
is there a student that like comes to
mind that has a story that there's a
lesson inside of
oh yes yeah definitely i can you know
yeah i have uh i have a lot of stories
of students and it's easier it's more
difficult when it's something personal
when it's something very close
you know like very you know when you
have to tap into your pain kind of thing
that's more that's when it comes more
difficult
but i mean it it should be more
difficult
yeah you know and and but like even even
with a student it might be painful
like maybe you let them down or maybe
they disappointed you or maybe you made
a mistake or
it could be you know a million different
things that potentially went wrong
um not just talking about the inspiring
stories but also some of the ones that
where you felt pain and then how did you
get through it are you still working
through it
yes yeah yeah definitely yesterday i had
one like
just yesterday yeah there's always you
know stories happening around everyone's
life right and yesterday i had a refusal
uh for one of my students
and uh you know i when whenever that
happens i you know i need to address and
talk and explain what happened and uh
husband was okay wife not so much and uh
you know it was at the end of the
afternoon i took this appointment at the
end of the afternoon and because i
wanted to talk to them i wanted to
address as soon as possible but uh you
know she said something like you know
she should be more enthusiastic about
reapplying she was harsh like you know
it is when i have a situation like this
it's hard for me as well because it's i
put a lot of work on it and it when it
doesn't work sometimes most of the times
work
sometimes it doesn't
so it's hard on me too so i heard i
heard say
she's saying that until it hurt it hurts
right but she was like well she at least
she should put more excitement on trying
to reapply
and
i understand her situation i understand
her position but at the same time it's
painful for the person because we're
we're not
kind of like infallible machines we are
and it's not my mistake it was not my
mistake sometimes it happens it's their
situation which is not ideal and you
know sometimes that happens
but i'm dealing with the with the
frustration it's hard
it's hard and uh and uh you know let's
see what happens with them like
hopefully i can turn okay so how did you
deal with the situation how did it make
you feel and how did you deal with it
at that point it was almost 6 p.m i was
with my energy very low
and
i recognized that she felt uh she felt
probably
dismissed like i was not really
feeling what they were feeling
so i told the house and i tell look i
understand
how frustrating is this because it's not
just a no to a paper it's a no to a
dream you have
and but we we set clear expectations
from the beginning so you knew that this
could happen
so it's uh not that i'm not enthusiastic
if you want to proceed and reapply we
will
and you know we will do the best uh we
can
and uh you know it's not that i don't
feel your pain
so i that wasn't as much as i could do
my energy it was not
you know like probably i could do
something better but
that's what i managed to do at that time
and with you know that
mindset so think about that story
what would the lesson in the story be
there's a lot of different ways you
could take it
what's the lesson for people in that
story
the lesson is that
sometimes
you
have to deal
with
a negative outcome
regardless how much effort you put
sometimes happens
especially if it's not under your
control
but
probably what i would say is important
is to be upfront from the beginning
so there is no like
major damage beyond what you know of
course the disappointment and the time
and those things
it's uh it's it's hard when these
situations happen
for people it's very frustrating and
they react different ways that's the
lesson that's something everybody here
can connect to
the details of the story
don't matter
like the the person's name doesn't
matter the person gender doesn't matter
what they're hiring you for doesn't
matter
all that matters is you were trying to
do something for a client and you didn't
get the result that they wanted
and
they
made you feel really bad with a with a
with a comment out of frustration and
how it made you feel and then what you
did afterwards
you could tell that story
like you can tell that story in two ways
you can tell the story like you told us
and you can include the name you can say
hey
you know jose you know it was my client
who hired me to do this and it got
rejected
and and then his wife said this person
tanya doesn't care like you can go into
all the details
but those don't really matter as much as
the summary is you've got a client
who
is not happy with you and said something
mean about you
out of their frustration
at the end of a really long day
like how do you show up
so what really matters inside that story
is how did it make you feel
and then what did you do afterwards
so when they say hey tanya
it doesn't even look like she's trying
the most important part of the story is
how did that actually when when she said
those words how did that make you feel
i'd have you've been putting the effort
and the work and you're trying and you
do this and we set expectations and
then they said this and it just like
that's the most important part did it
crush you did you cry did you need to go
meditate like what those you know or
just like but if there's no emotion to
it then then it's not really a story
worth sharing if you can just brush it
off and get back up then it doesn't
really matter but if when something hits
you like say that did destroy you say
those words like
just crushed you
then that's a story that you can share
without
naming the client or if they watch the
video they may not even know it's them
like it doesn't have to reference them
you could change the gender
it doesn't matter what they're hiring
you for all that matters is how the
situation made you feel and what you did
afterwards that's the lesson so in
telling a story if i'm going to tell a
story
about zen there's lots of stories i
could tell about zayn you know it's like
well what's what's the what's the
outcome that i like what's the lesson i
want people to have
and then i can tell the right story
around it and i don't even have to have
it as zane
like if there was something that was
gonna be
you know if if uh
you know zayn zan and i met up in vegas
last week or last month and uh
uh
he he was supposed to wear a mask the
whole time this is a good full this is a
fun one uh his wife insisted that he
wear a mask the whole time and he didn't
wear a mask
you know for almost any of it
and so it could be it could be about
environment like why well because he's
in a room where nobody's wearing a mask
and it feels awkward and uncomfortable
to be the only one wearing the mask and
and so he told his wife that he was not
wearing the math and so
i could make that about environment like
the environment you're in really matters
if you're around people who are doing
the things that you want then
um
you're more likely to be pulled up but
if you're around people who are living
the way that you don't want
or is against what you said you would do
it's a lot harder to stay consistent
and uh
i wouldn't tell that story about zayn
publicly on my youtube channel
you know i i would i the fact that he's
here and you can hear me say it and it's
in like a fun group we can i'll do that
but uh i wouldn't share that story as an
example on my youtube channel without
him hearing it
um
but i could still share that story about
i could i could change it up like i was
at this event and i was i met an
entrepreneur who said that
she wanted to wear masks the whole time
and and she promised people in her life
that she would and then as soon as she
came out she didn't like she was walking
around without the mask on like wait
what happened like well nobody else is
wearing a mask like you just changed it
up without identifying zayn change the
gender say that entrepreneur like it
doesn't matter that it's in
right
um there's very few circumstances where
it actually does like if it's your mom
or your parents or something then maybe
there's something really deeply personal
it's like it'd only be them
it could only be them
um
you know there's abuse or something like
it can only be them
um
but most stories you can easily flip
around because the point is you're how
you felt in your journey through it not
so much about the specifics of the
person
anyway i hope that helps tanya and we
went we went along on it but i think
it's valuable for others who are kind of
struggling with with the same thing and
definitely i struggled with too and what
i'm saying is not
it's simple but it's not easy
especially when you're diving into like
the the the emotion of how it made you
feel
the most important thing if i was going
to tell the zan story about
um environment
i'd have to connect it like i would make
it even stronger for me how did it make
me feel
am i am i
upset that he's um
not doing it am i
am i upset that am i disappointed in
myself for not being a better
role model should i have worn a mask
like whatever no i don't actually care
enough about it it's just more of a
funny story but if it like how does it
impact me
is what makes for a much better story
so how does it impact you that creates
like that emotion that you have is the
thing that's worth diving into more than
the specifics of what happened in the
story maria's got her hand up what do we
got maria
thank you evan actually i have something
that sort of piggybacks off of tanya's
question so great and maybe i missed it
but i've been listening but anyway when
i when i share like an example i say i
work i recently worked with a client
and i give an example and i because my
niche is women i don't really change the
sex
um
but i i wouldn't say their name of
course
unless of course they you know like said
oh share this story publicly but i still
feel like
i just feel sometimes after i do it like
it feels like it flows and it's the
perfect thing because it is an example
of what needs to be said at that moment
like it's not like premeditated even it
just sort of comes up you know like oh
that's interesting i just worked with
the client and
but then afterwards i sort of feel
there's two things i feel a little
uncomfortable because i don't because
i'm afraid they're going to recognize
themselves and the other thing is i'm
thinking when other people hear that are
they going to be worried that i'm going
to like if they work with me are they
going to be worried that i'm going to
share oh i just worked with a client
and we had this problem
so
i don't know if i'm like overthinking it
or what are your thoughts on that
still like how do you you know share an
example you work with a client who what
who um
i mean perfect example would be
um
yesterday i was working with a client
and
she was struggling
so she's struggling with a lot of guilt
and when someone her partner says to
harlow your beliefs create your reality
it makes her even feel guiltier because
it's like look at the mess that i've
created you know and and so it spirals
it spirals her down he is intending to
uplift her right
and but really it's creating even more
of of the problem for her
that's a little bit of an example of
what i might say if we were talking
about that how the insidiousness of
guilt can creep in in
just what's showing up in your life
and and then what's the what's the
lesson what's the message out of that
the message out of
out of that um particular thing is we we
worked on the guilt that was showing up
around that because it had not so much
to do with the circumstance it was the
guilt that was just sort of rearing its
head in all different areas
right so that means so that's the story
but what's the message like you need to
eliminate guilt from your life or what
what's what's the what's the takeaway
like the whole point of telling a story
is to have some kind of take care that i
can go so yeah i hear that story yeah i
mean i'm just sort of
not even like thinking through this
whole no no no no i'll get it i get
we're workshopping it that's what we're
doing here together so so the message
would be that it comes down to a belief
that she has about herself that she's
not enough
and that the you know
let's start addressing the guilt that's
showing up it's not that he needs to
change what he's saying to her so much
it's an opportunity for her to realize
that this circumstance is triggering the
guilt but the guilt is in her
it's not the circumstances right so
that's what we and that's
based on a false premise that she's
there's something wrong with her or
she's not enough or she has to do it
perfectly or because that's like the
core issue that we've been working on
okay so there's a couple this is
interesting now so what what would be
the single biggest takeaway from
this story what do you want people to
walk away with
oh so um
there's nothing wrong with you it's not
about the circumstances
if you're if if you're plagued with
guilt
it's not
it's
there's a false premise there's a false
belief there's an erroneous belief that
you've you picked up in life it's not
who you truly are you're valuable you're
worthy you're enough
but all that stuff is getting in the way
of you seeing yourself that way
and so the opportunity is when stuff
like this comes up into your life
it's a it's sort of mirroring back to
you how you feel not so much because
you're a bad person is it's it's like
goes back to the belief creates a
reality is that that reality is showing
up because it's showing you that you
have this belief that you're not enough
and that's what we can change
right because it's
the guilt is sort of like the outer
piece of you know that's an indicator
and we talked we had a whole
conversation around guilt and shame
because the real issue far was
perfectionism and perfectionism is
really usually a cover for not you know
guilt and shame so it sort of goes deep
but that but the takeaway is that these
erroneous beliefs that we
we
pick up along the way are not really who
who we truly are and they get in the way
of us reaching our you know
living our successful life
so this is this is um this is great
thank you for kind of being our guinea
pig and being on the spot it's it's fun
to workshop these things because i go
through this too trying to figure out
storytelling
um you have two options
either you
start with a message and then you look
for a story or you start with a story
and look for the message but you need
both right like a a a message of the
story is not as powerful in a story
without a message like what am i here
what am i learning so if i was going to
talk about environment matters maybe i
then go and find a story like zan in
vegas or if i start with zen in vegas
there's a thousand stories there's a
thousand stories i can pick to kind of
get the message right so i gotta go
you can both work so if you're coming
out of a session with a client
out of this one
why i was trying to kind of figure out
the path is because from this one
conversation with this woman you could
tell eight different stories and have
eight different messages
in what you're sharing about erroneous
beliefs that you pick up along the way
is not who you truly are like if that's
what we're trying to get around then
what the husband said to her doesn't
even matter
right well it mattered to her in the
moment but but the right but it doesn't
it doesn't of course it yes of course
and you covered a lot in your call but
to to yours to your message of what
you're trying to get out
you don't have to say the husband's
story at all
if it's just about the fact that she has
been plagued by guilt
you don't have to talk about the husband
in that situation
if you're going to talk about how the
people around us
you mentioned environment a little bit
and like the people around us talking to
okay then that the relationship matters
and the husband could be a friend or the
husband could be someone in their life
right
but
your message is more about her own
internal beliefs
and believe that she's not enough
and so where does that come from and how
is that manifested in her life and some
of the things that she's trying to do
you could tell that whole story without
talking with the husband at all if the
message was
the belief that you're not good enough
okay
so what we did was he took a okay and i
i threw you up
you know right this was not plan to
prepare so like thank you for
participating in in you know and playing
catch with me but i think it's something
that we go through as trying to create
the stories to share in our videos is
you okay give me an example so in the
example
really there's like three or four or
five different potential messages from
that one example and if you i'm sure you
can go with another 10 if you needed to
based off of just thinking back to the
actual experience with her
and so it's it's only telling the things
that are relevant if one makes for a
much better video
right it's like like why are we bringing
the husband into this that doesn't even
make sense it doesn't fit the storyline
that one's that one example
um
[Music]
and so asking yourself like what's the
message from this story
can help align
clarity same thing with tanya like
what's the message from this well the
message is
um if the message for her was that
you know bad things happen and you have
to bounce back from it then
all the details over who the client was
and what they doesn't doesn't matter so
it allows us to tell the story and cut
out the details that might identify
somebody or make them feel upset
and we're keeping in the things that
only matter to that specific story
okay does that make sense
yeah
yeah you could tell a great story about
her talking about guilt
that never identifies her that doesn't
bring in the husband and just how guilt
is holding is holding her back and then
what you did to release the guilt so
what we had to do was we did
x one i sat and listened to her and two
i told her to
like whatever the advice was to help
get her out of nothing actually
what's that he did emotional tapping
cool so like here's what we did so we
started tapping and like and and now
you're just talking about a woman who
has guilt
you know it's like
everybody has guilt
everybody believe has erroneous beliefs
that we've picked up along the way now
it's something that's really
relevant to the people you're trying to
serve well the key though that the real
the breakthrough came in the in the
session
was as we uncovered all of that
and we did some tapping around because
the emotion you know the guilt was
that at one point i just spontaneously
said to her
you didn't create like the creating
piece was like getting in the way of
create the reality i think
for like her whole lifetime she was
feeling like
she created
the prop the fact that she doesn't feel
good enough like she keeps beating
herself up and i said just
like spontaneously said i said you
didn't create that
and that like hit her and she's like
that's like
ready to turn my life around because
i've been blaming myself that i've
created
you know all that stuff and i was like
you're this innocent child in a theta
state that just picked up those beliefs
you didn't create them in the first
place you know
yeah so i mean that so now we have
that's a message right you didn't create
those beliefs so if you're gonna follow
the structure now from built to serve
you've got your powerful beliefs your
powerful opinion the
beginning you did not create those
negative beliefs in your head
powerful opinion right like
context sentence
the the voice in your head that's
telling you that you can't do it and
you're not good enough
is not your voice those are planted in
you by other people
right contact sentences racist takes
if you do not fix this voice in your
head you will continue to believe the
lies that are keeping you small good
right powerful opinion so powerfully
content sentences raise the stakes cool
story
so the other day i was talking to one of
my clients and she's this beautiful
woman who was dealing with a lot of
guilt
and
i was on a call with her and and she's
sharing her story about how she doesn't
feel good enough and how she doesn't
feel she's capable and she's got all
these amazing dreams inside her for what
she could create but just never takes
the steps to make it happen and so as we
started doing a tapping exercise that
i'd love to do with my clients
it flowed through me that
i said you did not create those beliefs
and that was her biggest aha takeaway
moment
that she stopped
and she said
you're right or like like whatever like
we can adjust some of the rent but she
said you're right and that became the
big breakthrough moment for her because
she had lived her entire life feeling
like she
wasn't good enough and that that voice
was hers and she was blaming herself and
she was blaming herself for doing it
right
yeah
and so
i'm here to tell you that those now we
move on that's the story i'm going to
tell you that
those beliefs are not yours they were
planted in you
and so now we have to do the work to
identify who planted it and how to get
it out here's what we're gonna do step
one we're gonna start tapping
right and so like you tell the story but
it could be almost anybody like who who
hasn't i'm that woman
yeah
right
so that allows you to tell the story and
then and then you move into giving
advice and tapping and whatever else you
you want to do but um
it's not personally identifiable at all
we're not talking about her husband in
that situation and it could be
right you could easily say and on
june 2nd i met with sally tom thompson
and she told me this about her husband
you know it's like then it's obviously
we wouldn't do that but there's a way to
tell a story like that that um
i mean i just made that up based off of
what you told me yeah it was great
years i'm good at that
well let's just practice i wasn't good
at that right just practice going
through the process
hello everybody we're back and and we're
ready to go and so usually there's one
theme for the week and then open it up
to q a whatever you guys want to talk
about tony's already got his hand up so
that's exciting samar asked why mindset
matters and so just you know quick riff
i guess on mindset
i think lack of belief is the world's
biggest problem right like whether you
believe you can or you can't you're
right and
most people
are just stuck most people feel trapped
most people are around
other negative people who also feel
trapped and so you might occasionally
have this idea that great things are
possible but then you fall back to
the negative mindset and everybody else
around you and you stay stuck um
i just came back from uh
from speaking at two events in in
phoenix a genius network and the first
one people paid 25 000
a year to be in the second one is you
pay a hundred thousand dollars to be in
and my
uh
my last day i had a morning coffee with
a guy who had
sold his business for over 200 million
dollars
and now is helping other entrepreneurs
be more efficient and productive in
their businesses
and
you know he he picked me up from my
hotel and we drove to his house and then
he eventually drove me to the airport
and his house is more like a compound
it's not not just a house it's like a
house and an entire house just for his
recording studio for he plays guitar and
another house just for his taekwondo
studio for him to practice and like four
houses in one house and
more than any bit of advice
that he gave me and similar to just
being in those groups it's the
the mindset difference it's like trying
to do
life at a bigger level trying to have an
impact at a bigger level and for most of
us we are
that source of positivity for other
people
we are the ones believing in other
people and pouring into other people and
telling them that they can do it and
giving them love and encouragement and
support but who's telling us that we can
do better and in a loving way not like
you should be doing this this this we
got lots of those people but who's
pushing your loving way forward and for
the most part
we don't have those people so that's why
i love a group like this that's why i
love groups like movement makers um and
just in general trying to be around more
optimistic positive people because
sometimes it's hard for kerry for us to
carry the whole burden
of positivity and optimism for ourselves
and so if
you are the most optimistic person you
know that's in your immediate circle
um that's a problem
you know like it's great that you can
don't stop pointing other people but if
you don't have anybody who's pouring
into you then that keeps us stuck and it
keeps us small and so the mindset shift
to feel like hey i can do more i can be
more i can serve more can have a bigger
impact
i think becomes really important so the
the whole idea of you are the five
people you surround yourself with really
matters and if you don't know anybody
then get in a group or come back to you
know a group like this um or even just
through content
right that i haven't met elon musk yet
but i i i get inspired by his videos and
his content and his moves like elon musk
is buying twitter what
doesn't he already have four of the
companies that is running or something
it's like it just makes me question what
i'm doing not in a negative way like i
think comparison actually can be really
beneficial
a lot of people say don't compare
yourself to others and i think people
just compare themselves incorrectly they
look at somebody else and then they kick
themselves down and say i can't do it
where i like it as a kick forward say
wow look what elon musk is doing i can i
should be thinking bigger and it's an
inspiration to go off and do more
otherwise we stay stuck and stay small
so anyway that's my little quick riff on
why mindset matters thank you samar for
the topic and uh let's
let's open it up tony's got his hand up
what do we got tony
i have a personal
training and mission coaching business
for three five years now and for
33 years i was doing everything in
person until covet hit
switched everything virtual and online
but for probably the past eight years
since i was about 45-ish years of age
i've been posting
non-stop monday through friday on
facebook i've been emailing monday
through friday tomorrow's i started
doing instagram maybe a couple years ago
as well
i feel lost in that kind of virtual
world
so
we went through a great exercise this
morning movement makers where i'm
basically i told them that my number two
platform is now tick tock we decided
last week that youtube is number one and
it still is number one by far
but i've switched in the past
week
from instagram to tick tock as number
two
and so part of it is being smart with
where you're at because you could you
could be producing the best content ever
but if you're on facebook like facebook
has been dead for a long time
right there's no zero organic reach on
facebook it's a fantastic ad platform
but it it sucks for content um
instagram
is
slowly not dying but becoming less and
less and less and less and less relevant
it's harder to rank it's harder to win
um
we covered a little bit today but the
reels is still going to be your best bet
now like no more pictures it's reals so
i need to see reels i need to see short
form video content
um
and then
tick tock is definitely picking up steam
like we're over half a million followers
on tick tock and a quarter million on on
instagram and
it's taken me like six years to do that
on instagram in a year and a half or
whatever on tick tock and we're barely
taking tick tock seriously right like
instagram's been number one and we just
kind of post whatever to tick tock and
that thing is blowing up
um and it's becoming an education place
as well for people so it's not just
somebody commented like 16 year old
teenagers dancing or whatever there's
still that and there's fun but it's also
becoming an education platform and the
the easiest thing to do is go search for
what you're doing
what you teach
and and see what's on there and you'll
see that hey there's actually education
content on there so i love that you're
making content and i love that you're an
expert you've been doing this for so
long and you want to serve
i would look at
if i was getting started now and i
didn't have traction i would do youtube
long form
and tick tock short form but then i
bring to the other platforms
i would probably completely abandon
facebook unless it was just easy to post
or you had some kind of community there
already
um and the long-form youtube videos
would be
not hugely impactful in the short term
but you've been doing this for a while
and you want to keep doing this and so
um
getting whether they're actual workout
videos that you're going to do whether
they're coaching sessions that you have
with clients
you're imagining someone's going to see
this in a year and two years and three
years and
love what you're doing and sign up
youtube is the if you want to get off
the kind of rat race you know the
hamster wheel whatever youtube is it
because when you make content in a year
it's still relevant and valuable and can
drive traffic
every other platform is
it's insta like instagram it's instant
it's only what's happening right right
right right now it doesn't mean that it
can't help or can't convert
um but choice of platform and and choice
of content like if you're doing pictures
on instagram it's just
gone off a cliff so it's short form
video everybody wants short form video
now plus long form on youtube so i'd
look at a
if you're not consistent on youtube yet
i'd look at once a week making content
10 minutes plus no upper limit on how
long you can go and then a daily short
form
for tick tock that then you take to the
other platforms
great thank you okay let's move on lady
lexi what do we got hi there um
um
today is uh the dutch liberation day 77
years ago there are a number of
festivals there are going you say
liberation day
yeah dutch liberation day oh okay great
well happy happy liberation day yeah so
that's may 5th
and um with everything going on i'm like
i need to go to rotterdam go to one of
those festivals make a recording but i'm
like okay
what exactly am i going to talk about i
cannot just address all the people there
because i don't have a press badge or
anything so how do i make that work
because i feel like it's so important
that we get to speak out and and so i
can either go there or i can do it from
here
what what would you suggest
hold on what are you speaking out
against so it's okay dutch independence
day cool today is 77
anniversary awesome oh that we got
liberated by the english and by the
americans and there might even be some
canadian
okay so
the idea is hey you need to like you
want to recognize them
have it i don't was a revolution or was
it a you know like how like they're
speaking up for themselves
so important
and i mean especially when with what's
going on in ukraine it makes my heart
cry you since my my mother is about
speaking up and speaking out this is
about
people back then were of course being uh
delegated basically to to do the to the
camps and put work there and they were
not recognized as people
so it's not necessarily that i want to
speak out for what happened there i just
want to
you know say like okay let's celebrate
freedom let's remember that it's
important that we do speak up and speak
out
what we what we see and what we find
should change and also on a personal
level
so i mean that could be a great so if
the message is speaking out for freedom
then that's something that people can
connect with because we want to target
ideally the world not just
holland right so
most people wouldn't know that it's
dutch independence day or how many
however many years it's been or how
holland even came out of
you know like most people know the story
and the story
almost doesn't matter unless it really
means something to you but if you were
gonna go
and make it not just what happened 77
years ago but where do people need more
freedom right now like it's a good
trigger as a reminder so
i'm canadian and but like we don't um we
don't we have we have canada today but
it's not really that big a deal in
canada um but americans take their
independence day pretty seriously right
and so on july 4th in america
if you were to go off and talk to people
about about freedom
but then make it reflective as to where
do you not have enough freedom in your
life right now
and not just from like the government
imposing something on you but your own
situation like where are you stuck in a
relationship are you stuck in a bad
career are you stuck in bad habits are
you stuck with an addiction like if you
can tie the need for freedom to
something they're facing right now in
their life then it can lead to
speaking up like for yourself if you're
in a bad relationship hey maybe you need
to get out if you're in a bad
career maybe now is the time so you can
use this event as a spark plug to create
some change so you could go if you want
to go to the event you don't need a you
don't need a press badge to talk to
people
you just go on the street and you ask
people about what freedom means to them
but then make it relevant to today like
well where do you not have enough
freedom right now do you think in your
life
and then guiding them to a path of
speaking up
okay
uh okay yeah it's going to be a big step
for me you know dressing people randomly
at a festival
um but yeah but listen lean in on that
because this is now you speaking up
yeah that's good yeah it's a good
challenge absolutely
this is how you've never done it before
and this is now you
going after your freedom because you
don't want to be you don't want to have
that
blocking mindset anymore
yeah and you may have people who say no
would i want to talk to you no i hate
you i mean whatever you like think of
like worst case scenario
um but you'll have some people who will
talk to you
yeah yeah that's nice and then maybe i
can do some shorts some short lives
and then later on make it into a big one
and post it on youtube honestly the
biggest thing the biggest win out of all
of this
isn't the content you're gonna get from
them it's from you pushing yourself
outside the comfort zone
okay that makes sense the fact that like
one person might say yes to you and
you're so scared to ask people to come
on and then you get one person to do it
even if it's not the greatest
conversation of all time like that
forward momentum and you breaking
through
like that should be a video you should
film yourself going
and how scared you are and what whatever
thoughts are in your head
and you're basically speaking up to your
own thoughts to say you know what no i'm
gonna i'm gonna go do this and even if i
if i embarrass myself if nobody talks to
me
i'm still gonna go off and do it
i saw a great clip yesterday on
instagram where um
this guy was a stutterer
so he like he gets nervous and then he
can't talk and and his coach i know you
guys have seen this his coach had him go
out in a busy area and
go up to people
and ask them to like hey can you help me
for a second and all he then would ask
him is what time is it
but it took him forever to get it out
because he was so nervous and when he
gets nervous he starts to stutter and so
he's like
excuse me
it's like they're sitting there waiting
for him to like
what's going on right now and eventually
he says you know what time is it
and um and he also just shared the story
with them like i must i'm a stutterer
and i'm trying to
be less scared and stutter less since
this is part of my
my homework
so even you sharing your story like
that's i think the biggest win of all is
you sharing your story that where you're
afraid and the mental block
um so that you get your own freedom from
those limiting thoughts too
yeah that's good one so i can just take
my phone i don't need any microphones or
anything right
yeah especially if you're doing two
people because if the microphone's just
here then it's harder to share
and don't worry about the gear just go
do it okay
i'll do it thank you i love it cool good
luck that's super exciting
welcome board guys good to have
everybody back
uh today's topic was interesting is
giving yourself permission to live out
your purpose
um
man it took me a long time to get
comfortable with being up front
uh with being being the guy being in
front
i used to always feel like it was an ego
trip
that i didn't i didn't have to be famous
i had no need to be famous
um i fought with my agent for years on
it
and
it wasn't until i really realized that
sharing my story was actually selfless
that people could see themselves in me
if they don't know
your story they won't listen to your
advice
you know you look at evan there the
other evan
not this side we got evans back to back
but evan looks like he's got it all
together he's all figured out he's got
this nice shirt on and the pictures
behind him and he looks like he's all
he's got it all figured out and if
imagine if the guy who you see in front
of you is making videos about how to get
out of alcohol addiction be like yeah
but you don't understand me dude look at
you you've got this fancy life you've
got it all figured out meanwhile
he knows
he knows exactly what it's like
and so until you share your story i've
been sharing his story me sharing my
story you guys sharing your story it's
not about you it's not about people
just praising you for what you've come
through it's about
other people being able to see
themselves and you
that
people won't listen to me as much for
getting out of alcoholism because that i
didn't struggle with that that's not
that wasn't something that i had a
challenge with but evan tinsman he did
and so
if you didn't know that about him you
wouldn't want to listen to him i got
another guy tell me what to do he
doesn't get it
so that's why it's super important that
you share your story and and give
yourself permission to share the story
uh that that if you guys can pick that
up quickly that's amazing because that
literally took years for me to figure
out years of fighting years of pushing
by people close to me like my agent
who's like
just
frustration on his part i'm sure to
slowly convince me and it wasn't until i
realized that hey sharing my story is
actually serving
and we go through it in in and built the
server as well there's sections on that
but um
yeah giving yourself the permission to
do it is
super valuable and um
anyway i hope i hope that mentioned the
deal i hope that helped you anyway the
point of these sessions is yes kind of
lead with a quick thought like that but
but i want to be able to help you guys
out this we've turned it into the little
mini live coaching sessions whatever
you're struggling with however i can
help
get your movement off the ground um
let's let's open it up what do you guys
what's what's going on how can i be of
value who wants to go first
i'll go first all right let's go first
so i know that when you first started
you did all the
promoting and content for your videos
and that you know for your stuff
at what point did you hire somebody and
now when you hire somebody what exactly
do you have them to do like for if you
if i were to hire somebody in my content
do they actually create the content not
the videos but the content and edit
that's my question
so
the
first person i ever hired in my business
this wasn't my business right the first
person i ever hired was to do data entry
for me because i hated data entry and he
was actually much better at it than i
was and so he took two hours off my
table and he gifted that to me and i
paid him and it only took him an hour
because he was faster and better at it
than i was on the youtube side of things
i the first hire was an editor part-time
and this really comes down to like what
do you want to be great at
so there's no right or wrong answer it's
the right wrong answer for you
i did not want to be great at editing i
like at the very beginning of things i
like messing around with stuff i like
playing around i like seeing
the ins and outs of it and so i quickly
picked up movie maker which is probably
the most basic video editing
software that you can use so i picked
that up um got used to it but then
quickly realized that i don't i don't
like this i'm not good at it and i don't
like it
i wasn't good in front of the camera
either belinda i mean if you watch my
videos i watch it back it's like i'm not
good at that either but
i like it you know i want to get better
at it i want to improve video editing i
didn't like it and i didn't want to get
better and i didn't want to improve so i
knew that that would always be a
limitation for me that i would i would
force myself to do it if i had to but
as soon as i could get that off my plate
then i would so
the hiring a part-time editor was my
first hire and i think a lot of you can
you can you don't hire full-time you
don't have to just go out and hire
somebody full-time to help you you can
hire somebody part-time project work
um a couple hours a day or even a couple
hours a week depending on what you're
doing so it's really figuring out what
do you hate the most that has to get
done
and then and then working on that so for
me was editing
now when i hire it really just depends
on what what the need is right we've got
30 something people on the team
so
you know if i'm hiring somebody just to
be in charge of my linkedin content that
that may not be
the best strategy for you for where
you're at right now um but if anybody's
trying to be in front of the camera and
that's where your genius is then editing
becomes the fastest one so it's editing
part-time editor to then full-time
editor to then he got kidnapped so i had
to get another editor that was a crazy
story he just disappeared for for three
or four months this guy was super
reliable always on time and then like
just dropped off the face on the map
and then he came back like three four
months later and said sorry evan
i got kidnapped
it's crazy crazy right i need i need you
know some personal time i mean i'm home
now i'm safe i was held for ransom
um
yeah just
crazy but in that period like where is
he i'm sending messages back and forth
nothing happened and then um i found
christina my my current editor now who's
been with me for i don't know how many
years many many many years and then we
hired her husband um then i hired a
researcher so that we can
again like slowly niching down what do i
want to be great at i
love doing the research on the videos
but i love
being in front of the camera more and
spreading the message more so that i
hired somebody to help me do the
research
uh so you slowly take away the pieces of
what you don't like doing or don't want
to be the world's greatest at so you can
focus on what you could be
does that make sense
all right
thank you all right good actually
question myself
fonda why dude i didn't even recognize
you with that hat on fun the white in
the house i love it dude that smile
but i was just wondering about
youtube and i know you guys said you
know create content every day
but i'm actually my youtube channel and
my videos i'm actually doing the editing
and everything myself
so it's not difficult to do it every day
but i guess there's ways to
i guess do it every day when you're
doing
everything you know
don't edit
yeah
no like for for your ambitions like
fonda wants to be a speaker
so
the skill
so if you're making a video how long
does it take you to a typical video how
long does it take you to record it
versus edit it and do all the other
stuff with it
record it not not so long but editing
probably about 30 40 minutes and how
long to record it uh i do little clips
so each clip is about my videos are no
longer than
six seven minutes
so if you're spending more time editing
than recording you're spending all your
time
training the wrong skill
right
you want to be spending more time
speaking you're trying to train yourself
to be a great speaker this is just
imagine every time you pull out your
phone or whatever you're using to
record that you're on you're on some
stage
that's the skill you need to develop so
if i'm you i would
do zero editing
okay to train yourself that from the
second you press record that it's like
you're on stage because when you're on
stage you don't get editing there's no
editing yeah so it's a good skill to
practice look if you if you if you only
train yourself that i can only be a good
speaker and deliver a message when it's
been cut up and edited
you're never going to be great on stage
right
so treat every video like a stage work
whether you're whether you're in your
room there whether you're walking
outside you know whatever i still make
videos from my phone and my car for my
clients nina's going to costco great
film
[Laughter]
start recording rise and shine and since
festive time let's go
uh yeah
zero editing
okay
because what's going to get you to the
point where you can then hire an editor
it's not going to be you
producing a video every couple days
with your kind of crappy editing
right yeah and i'm i'm not trying to
insult you just no no i get it be honest
right like you don't you don't want to
be a great editor
so the thing that will get you to the
spot where you can hire an editor is the
speaking because that's what you want to
be great at
right so if you're anybody here who
wants to be a speaker you need to be
putting up daily videos practicing you
speaking erasmus got his hand up and a
thumbs up like every day i need to see
you speaking because you'll get
discovered
through those videos but then you get
paid to go do speaking gigs
but then you use that money to hire a
team to now help you edit the videos so
that they're crisper
but okay no editing is going to save you
if your speaking sucks
right
and if you're speaking as fire it
doesn't matter what kind of editing is
on it
right yeah
it's like nobody's tuning out because oh
my god this guy doesn't have lower
thirds on his on his video are you
kidding me right if i'm out
right it's like can you speak to their
soul that's all that matters
yeah so zero editing i just i've just
given you more than double your time now
to actually go and make videos
okay thank you thank you
cool man
hi ivan this is iphone here sorry i'm
not camera ready it's iphone hello
so i'm
i'm an international nurse and i would
like to write a book to write my stories
uh to what extent i should like uh
reveal my story at the other technical
um
part of my nursing experience what is
the perfect balance and mixed
to relate with my audience
so if you if you go through the thought
leadership template in here you'll see
that story is super important it's not
the whole thing like it shouldn't be
half your story if you're not writing a
biography but the story has to be at the
beginning as a setup
because before they're willing and this
is forever you know fond of making
videos all of you if you're making any
kind of content i have to know your
story and where you come from before i'm
willing to listen to your advice so you
might be able to say hey here's how you
do xyz which is what all of us just want
to teach
that's in our hearts like you want to
teach you want to help you know you have
knowledge that can serve people you just
want to tell them one two three go do it
the problem is people don't do it
they don't do it because you didn't
connect with them emotionally first
they have to know that you understand
them because when you give the advice
they just say okay easy for that person
easy for you to say you don't understand
me right back to the very top when it's
talking about evan tinsman so the
beginning is is the story so that i know
who you are where you come from that
you're exactly like me and then you
achieved and then the rest is going to
be
the tips the advice the tactics the
strategies of how to actually win
okay
daniel's putting them in on a new hat
hustle first all right hustle hustle or
hustle what does that say hustle hustle
first all right i got it yeah
yeah evan justin following with that
idea
um
would you suggest putting your stories
out of a series of youtube things like
if they were two to four minutes long uh
putting your content into a story over
two or three videos or do it all at once
if you have a
sequence that you're going to put out in
an email for example or on your website
for example then that can make sense but
when people are just on youtube they
don't consume videos sequentially right
okay if you look at my videos you
haven't watched all my videos in order
i mean there's like
six or seven thousand public ones so it
might be scary if you've watched all of
those and we have to do a competition
like who's watched them i want to see
your watch history who's watched the
most videos from the channel um yeah
first off like a two to four evan
tinsman is already claiming himself to
be the winner
[Laughter]
um
a two to four minute video is never
going to do well on youtube period
but if you're if you're embedding it on
your website if you're putting it as
part of your email sequence for people
who want to learn about you that can
work
the story bit again i would follow the
model in built to serve you're trying to
teach but inside your argument is a
story that relates to it right and
you've got you've got time all of you
have tons of stories that you could
share
it's picking the one right story for
this piece of content that you're about
to talk about so if i'm going to talk
about youtube i have a story if i'm
going to talk about belief i have a
different story right
same thing for me i have millions of
different stories it's finding the one
right story but you wrap it inside of
the theme and the content
and giving advice at the end not just
your story and hoping that they watch
your sequence
yeah yeah yeah because i like that idea
of having a hook at the end of it just
kind of say bring them in okay so now
you've heard me um you know how can i
help you that kind of thing you know i
want to be there for you
yeah
okay evan
raise the finger
yeah i was actually just gonna share
that that um
i just put something out the other day i
don't i don't edit anything i just talk
um
but that's what actually i had a talk
with that family yesterday i'd mentioned
to you that they're actually flying me
to florida to help with someone and
they're paying me to do it all expenses
from just a little couple minutes that
they followed me with my journey but
from that somebody else had chimed in
and that gave me the topic of the video
that i just did a short one today and i
posted so if you share something of
whatever your personal story is and pay
attention to your comments people are
going to start asking because i did one
on addiction but then that turned into
hey evan how do you handle like the
stress and anxiety and that's what led
me to the one i'm doing now so
people's comments will pretty much tell
you what they want to hear
i love it and listen try to try to keep
the videos focused
and every piece of content focused
you have a lot of ideas all of you have
lots of ideas lots of wisdom lots of
things to share but if you're all over
the place with the advice and the focus
if it's about addiction just keep this
one video on addiction you can make more
videos on other things afterwards if
it's about having a powerful morning
routine then that's the video just keep
it tight and focused and then people
will dive into your world and want to
learn more about the other things that
you're doing
but i love that i mean congrats that's
that's the power of like if evan didn't
just release his video
and fonda i know you got a client from
just your videos too on on on instagram
like somebody
you dm them and they they hired you and
what for six months i hired you now to
coach them yeah three months three
months three months like that's amazing
i love it like you guys are getting
business by just
putting videos up on the internet
right but you know evan didn't release
that video because he didn't have time
to edit it today maybe he doesn't get
that deal where now he's being flown to
florida
right so
they're not hiring evan because of his
fancy editing and if you watch his
videos it's great he's either in his
chair there or he's in his car
and those are most of his videos and he
presses record and there's him talking
that that's that's what i want for all
of you guys to just release the burden
just make sure there's some kind of
light on your face right i mean go to
the window and have something in front
of you make sure you're not in the
middle of a windstorm or something
um super basic stuff but but you've got
you've got everything you need right
here in your phone press record and go
because you not producing a video a day
might have already cost you 10 clients
because you're worried about the editing
and that's not a fonda thing that's a
everybody here thing
raymond's dieting raymond's done eating
we like it welcome there he's gone
roswell you got a question or you're
just waving hi he's got a question okay
what do you got
yeah uh so evan when you say that you
want to see us like speaking every day
for us they want to be speakers
like how long do you think the content
should be or it just doesn't matter as
you go you get comfortable and they will
get longer
i want you to practice 10 minutes plus
10 minutes plus 10 minutes okay
if you can go deeper and go longer with
it great if you follow the template here
this it's a little hard to follow the
template by heart
uh as you go through it yeah i know i
know i know you got the book i know um
but at the end like the thought
leadership template
it's hard to remember everything right
it's hard to remember powerful opinion
contact sentence raise the stakes tell a
story three bits of
advice what do i'm just nervous to press
record in front of the camera
yeah right so at the beginning
just just think about the
getting that that hook at the beginning
like what's your powerful opinion
and then once you practice that like if
you if you're doing the 100 video
challenge just once once you get that
down then the three sentences into a
story
and then after the story then you
practice giving your opinion advice if
you follow that template you'll have a
10 minute plus video easy
okay there there okay daniel's daniel's
holding daniel's holding up screenshots
i like it
um thank you
yeah ten minutes plus it's because great
practice for youtube
um but for every video if you just
narrowed down to
powerful opinion
story and advice
if you're like at the very beginning
just think about those three things i'm
leading with an opinion i'm going to
share some kind of story and i'm going
to give advice
right
so if evan was going to tell the story
about flying to florida what's the
opinion at the top of that the the
florida story is the story and then he's
going to give advice
you know opinion
story advice
and as you as you get more comfortable
with that then you can work out some of
the nuances that we outline in the book
okay thank you another caller as well
get another call
all right raymond what do you got thank
you
hey what's up everybody sorry i was
eating i didn't eat breakfast i've been
on calls in the morning um
something interesting if you don't mind
if i could share i just recently learned
and i haven't been doing my youtube
videos i had to let go of my editor
because we didn't see eye to eye and he
wasn't in alignment with what i was
doing
um there's certain things that i learned
like i asked him to take notes on three
different occasions and he didn't and
then he did the things wrong i said
listen i've asked you three times i
think we're done
i tried to do it in the oreo cookie
where it's like with a comment and then
you know uh praise and then
you know with what's wrong but
anyway i've been on upwork and i've been
interviewing editors
working to build relationships so i
could do this
sorry
um on my podcast
and also one thing i learned i forgot i
think was from jenna kutcher that she
said when you do a video keep sharing
like i've been sharing it on linkedin
like every three days and because they
say six percent of people actually see
your videos
and so i did this
and i know they're scroll feeding all
kinds of things but i noticed just from
doing that if it's a good decent video
my second podcast is okay
but um i kept doing it and i just
noticed i would get more views and more
comments and people say dude cool wow
you know like you know engaging in the
weird ways that we do you know that's it
what's the main message of your channel
raymond uh the main message for the
podcast is just
working with with people inspiring
inspiring us to become the best versions
of ourself and learning from setbacks
failures and gaining feedback
okay great
so here's the thing when's the last time
you posted a video on youtube
uh a couple days ago so the whole
fallout with your editor was recent then
yes
yeah well he did it like he edited a
week ago and then i was doing the
youtube stuff you know making sure it
was aligned you know great people you
know to make sure i have the right
information but yeah it was recent
so so
i would say
it's i mean it sucks but that's part of
business yeah it means honestly it's
probably in the first you probably
already knew a little bit about that at
the beginning and you were trying to
make it right but it wasn't a fit
you know so so you'll be better on your
next hire it's fine and you leave with
the mission um what's your one word
what's your who
oh my who is freedom right so like
freedom you lead your upwork posting
talking about freedom how you're trying
to create freedom for yourself and
freedom for the people who watch your
content and how you wanna you wanna
build a mindset of freedom in this
company so somebody who wants to have
freedom themselves you know that's who
you want to bring on so you're going to
start attracting the right people
but you can't let this be
a reason for you not to post content
right
so you have to post to youtube because
if your message is how to bounce back
after setbacks
you got to demo it what are you doing
you're not posting videos you're in a
setback
yeah the video was hey guys it's raymond
this looks
not like my usual video but i have a
setback because somebody on my team left
but i don't want this to define me and
not have my videos go up so i'm if i
lost my whole team
i'm making videos dude
i felt and and and i was using this as
an excuse kind of like
my message wasn't clear compelling like
uh
i wanted to script it so i'm hitting on
points but i was i believe i was letting
that get in the way
you know and it's not that you can't
work on a better script and improving
but not at the expense of videos not
going up
i understand thank you you got like
fonda's got to get his videos up does he
have an editor no so he's going to do it
himself or just no editing get it up
like videos have to go up
release the perfection
like evan even said just do like a canva
pic and then just do like a
video and then that's it and then just
keep doing that until you know i will
fall into place i believe i believe
that's what happens tumbling blocks
turned into stepping stones but yeah 100
you can always go back later too as you
grow and fix all your old thumbnails and
titles and everything else but the thing
that will get you where you need to go
is you releasing content
so videos have to go up everything else
is secondary
so if you're giving it well i could do a
video
i could do a video every day or i could
do a video every two days but have it
with a good title and a good thumbnail
and edited video every day
okay to start training that skill to get
better with that thing especially when
your message is how to bounce back after
a setback yeah you gotta
demonstrate you doing it you're in the
middle of it i got a setback right now
guys
and and whatever's going through your
head of like i'm worried that you're not
going to like it i'm worried that it's
not edited well i'm worried that my
message isn't concise without somebody
cutting for me but whatever i'm not
going to let this hold me back do you
talk about the setbacks or no
yes yes okay that's personally
yeah like like dude did you watch me
make videos with my broken neck and like
giant scab on my face like every day i
made videos with a concussion like not
even knowing what i was saying
yeah
no
right
i mean evan saw me on that tour where he
saw me on the first day where i was fine
and then on the last day where i ended
up passing out on the floor afterwards
because
it's just that insane trip that i was on
but i it was i broke my neck in two
spots and had a concussion and said i
was making videos every day and i still
even if it was for five minutes would
make
a
video okay with like a huge scab like
giant on my forehead sitting there in a
in this neck brace not even to be able
to see properly and like oversized nike
pullover because i couldn't fit into
this thing propped up with like pillows
behind me and ice packs
dude
but i'm so proud of that i still keep my
neck brace here on the on my shelf i'm
proud of
struggling through it is it my best
content hell no no that's not my best
content
but like i did it
and for people who are going through the
journey that's an inspiration as well
the people will see you and say wow look
he's doing it too
yeah because when somebody loses someone
on their team what are they gonna what
are you gonna say you say oh yeah i get
it i did the same thing and i was like
no so you lose someone on your team you
keep going
here's what i did
yeah i mean i did i moved forward and
then i started putting out linkedin
intern ads
so i am moving forward just sometimes i
know it's slower than
but you're right video every day it's
always slower than you want yeah like ah
you know always slower than you want
everything is always so you want it
yesterday do it i want i want everything
yesterday it's always slower
and you get up and you keep doing
something today
yeah awesome thank you so much
i would say that's the best advice you
could give us for the week coming up i
mean if my volume is working why not
like throw it out there and give us
something to i don't know
just just uh you're right we have to
overcome struggles and poor struggle
into what we're doing and i know that's
how it works honestly the best advice is
like to
to get the content up whatever that
looks like for you
not everybody has has the ambitions to
go daily yet that might sound crazy for
some people here the idea of making
daily content but if you're struggling
to make one a week then one a week no
matter what you're struggling to make
three a week then three week you're
starting to make daily then daily no
matter what like even just show yourself
for a week
you film yourself there in your living
room making content even though normally
you'd be somewhere else with the
lighting set up and whatever like just
don't give yourself the out of
i'm gonna keep tweaking and keep making
it perfect having a deadline like we
keep trying to make our videos better
intros music
sources all of it always trying to hack
it to make it better and
there's no way that a video is not going
up today
so when you start with that as the basis
like a video has to go up today period
or if that's a post or if it's an email
or whatever that equivalent looks like
in your world for everybody here it has
to go up it has to go up
and then inside what's my best effort
and maybe your best effort is just you
and your room doing it maybe your best
effort means you can throw a little bit
of graphics on it maybe maybe you're
dead tired and you had a crazy day but
your best effort is you lying in bed
saying guys i
suck i'm so tired right now but i had to
make a video
post right and that's your video like
legit that is your video and you post
just to get it up
and build that muscle
whoo
guys thank you for the love
amazing super fun i have to pop uh zan
and i are on tonight if you want to join
in 6 p.m eastern on the gaming channel
um
yeah we'll be back again next week i
love
i love doing this i love hanging out
with you guys it's it's fun to see
repeat faces and also fun to see some
new faces if you're on next week uh
bring your questions again i want to see
you get your message out there to the
world because you got you got goodness
in here but it can't just stay here it's
got to get out there and we got to
overcome our fears and overcome
rejection and overcome all of our
insecurities to actually get that out
there so we can start actually have an
impact on the world i love you have a
fantastic end of the week and we'll see
you next week much love goodbye
everybody
we love you
if you want to get a copy of build to
serve and join us live for our next
training with me to ask your questions
you can go get the book right there next
to me right there i'll see you there
i'll see you to get the book it's a good
one much love